dozens are gathering outside the animal
foundation tonight to protest a recent
rise in euthanasia rates thanks for
joining us here at five o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus now
we first told you about this last night
record showing the shelter nearly
doubled the amount of dogs put down from
2021 to 2022. 8 news now reporter Sasha
Loftus has been following this story and
she joins us live with what the
protesters have to say
[Music]
this protest is starting to wrap up
tonight it did start around two o'clock
this afternoon you can see as few people
still out here with signs they were
chanting earlier all saying that this
recent rise in euthanasia rates
according to them is quote unacceptable
according to the animal foundation's
website dog euthanasia rates were up 91
percent that was from 2021 to 2022 while
intake in that same time only spiked
eight percent the number of cats put
down went up 61 percent again in that
same time period city councilwoman
Victoria Seaman was also in attendance
earlier today as we have reported she
did request an audit of the shelter six
months ago by the city that has not
happened quite yet we spoke to the
organizer of today's protest he says he
wants to see something change here
we've been out here before
um you know this organization has to
stop killing our animals and as a pet
parent
that breaks my heart
I can't even imagine what these animals
are going through
now we did reach out to the animal
foundation about these euthanasia rates
they sent this statement that reads in
part quote the animal foundation took in
almost 25
000 animals in 2022 as an organizational
policy only animals not considered to be
healthy and or treatable are candidates
for Humane euthanasia euthanasia rates
vary depending on the population of
animals we serve in a given month or
year end quote now back out here live as
I said this protest was originally set
to last until about six o'clock but they
said they should be wrapping up a little
bit after five now we did do a more
in-depth story about those euthanasia
rates here at the animal foundation last
night we have a link to that on our
website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now
all right so keep in mind the numbers so
far for 2023 euthanasia rates for dogs
are up again compared to this time last
year 157 dogs have been put down so far
this year compared to 107 in 2022 and
that's a 46 Spike the number of cats
euthanized has stayed relatively the
same right now so far this year 57 cats
have lost their lives